es ist glaube ich das größte versagens
eingeständnis was die bundeskanzlerin
überhaupt machen kann zu sagen ich bin
regierungschefin und ganz klar hinterher
sind wir alle schlauer der punkt ist
sehr entscheidend dass es diese warnung
ja gegeben hat über die dramatische
sicherheitslage und vor allem auch über
die folgen was denn passiert wenn die
amerikaner aus afghanistan abziehen es
ist nicht so dass auch die geheimdienste
das beispielsweise auch der
bundesnachrichtendienst nicht über die
vergangenen monate gewarnt hätte und
gesagt hätte achtung achtung da räumt
ein großes problem auch auf deutschland
zu auf die bundeswehr war die
sicherheitslage in afghanistan insgesamt
wird sich dramatisch verschärfen und
verschlechtern das heißt die
bundeskanzlerin tod hier so als wenn sie
eigentlich gar nicht vor informiert
worden wäre wenn sie überhaupt nicht in
der lage gewesen wäre diese situation
einzuschätzen und von einer
bundeskanzlerin von einer
regierungschefin glaube ich können wir
deutschen alle erwarten dass sie wenn
sie meint sie macht gute politik genau
das auch antizipiert beziehungsweise die
meldungen die warnung des gehabt in ihre
politik mit einfließen lässt und dann
umsetzt vor allem ganz kurz nur die
bilder die erinnern uns doch alle etwas
an syrien
2014/2015 familien die fliegen
verzweifelte mütter kleine kinder männer
die probieren irgendwie raus zu kommen
und jetzt zu sagen wir sind davon
überrascht und im nachhinein ist man
immer schlauer wir hatten doch davor
schon einmal eine ganz ganz ähnliche
situation westliche truppen die abziehen
islamisten die irland überrennen
menschen die panisch fliehen es gibt
dafür schon mal eine blaupause wir
wissen wie es ausgegangen ist und jetzt
stehen wir wieder am gleichen punkt wir
machen die identisch gleichen fehler und
man eine kanzlerin die kein plan keine
vision und auch kein konzept hatte wie
anfragen wir fragen wir jemanden wer
dabei war holen dazu die
cdu-bundestagsabgeordnete andreas
lindholz war dabei und ist uns jetzt
zugeschaltet quality hallo
wie würden sie es einschätzen war das
genug hat das gereicht was die kanzlerin
gestern gesagt hat
das ist natürlich eine subjektive
betrachtung aber
schon auch dass der besten hier ein
stück weit auch an seinen ansprüchen
gescheitert ist und mir persönlich ist
es auch zu wenig nur zu sagen haben den
falschen zeitpunkt verpasst ich hätte
mir auch ein bisschen mehr an der stelle
gewünscht und vor allen dingen auch
schon jetzt die frage wie werden wir das
aufarbeiten weil wir müssen daraus
rückschlüsse ziehen und wir haben auch
mit der bundeswehr in mali im einsatz
das heißt also wir müssen uns hier genau
anschauen wo man an welcher stelle was
hätte besser machen können in eine
durchaus schwierigen lage ich will das
nicht ich will das jetzt nicht im
nachhinein jetzt kleinreden aber es ist
eine schwierige lage und des währungs
verschlüsselt ausziehen würde ich mir
das dann vorstellen wie sie das
aufarbeiten
naja zum einen müssen uns für
nachrichtendienste schauen wenn sie in
der rückschau jetzt das betrachten und
sagen hätten wir an einer anderen stelle
noch
deutlichere warnungen ausgeben müssen
haben wir auf einen ebenen gut
funktioniert auch im internationalen
zusammenspiel und das gleiche wünsche
ich mir auch von der bundesregierung
dass man auch da sagt es hat ja immer
viele runden gegeben das thema
afghanistan ist er oft in den runden
auch behandelt worden das ist ja auch
ein langes thema das uns beschäftigt
aber hätte man jetzt gerade gegen ende
sage ich jetzt mal als auch klar war
dass die amerikaner das land verlassen
werden hätten wir da noch bessere
vorsorge treffen müssen hätten wir
diesen worst case den wir hier erlebt
haben hätte man ihn besser vorbereiten
können ich glaube da müssen alle ebenen
hinschauen und können nicht sagen warum
es immer abgestimmt und wir waren zu nah
an netzen zu einer anderen einschätzung
gekommen und das war's jetzt sondern
hier ist aus meiner sicht eine ganz ganz
wichtige aufklärung zu leisten das ist
für die menschen die jetzt noch davon
betroffen sind dass es eben nicht
optimal gelaufen ist natürlich nur ein
schwacher trost aber wir haben immer
auch die aufgabe mit blick auf die
zukunft eben zu gucken dass nicht wieder
dass so was eben nicht noch mal in der
art und weise und so ungeordnet passiert
wie das jetzt eben zum schluss leider
der fall ist
könnte sie sind chefin des
bundestagsinnenausschusses damit
eigentlich die mächtigsten
politikerinnen des bundestages haben
gerade doch in deutlichen worten auch
die regierungserklärung der
bundeskanzlerin kritisiert und sagen es
muss aufgearbeitet werden warum denn
sperrt sich die union warum sperren sich
union spd dann gegen einen
untersuchungsausschuss wie er von der
opposition gefordert wird
ich muss ihnen ehrlich sagen für mich
ist das mit dem untersuchungsausschuss
jetzt definitiv nicht der richtige
zeitpunkt wir haben noch die aktuelle
lage zu beherrschen das heißt im
vordergrund stand jetzt und steht immer
noch die menschen zu retten die
ortskräfte raussuchen die deutschen
rauszuholen und auch wenn das nicht mehr
möglich ist durch verhandlungen die
situation weiter zu stabilisieren und
auch noch weitere ausreichend zu
ermöglichen das steht für mich im
vordergrund
das ist der bundestag ist auf absehbare
zeit gewählt unsere amtszeit endet und
in welcher weise das aufgearbeitet wird
das sollte der nächste bundestag
entscheiden ich finde sogar dass es der
anstand und der respekt vor dem nächsten
bundestag gehört zu sagen mit der
endgültige entscheidung wie das
aufgearbeitet wird warten wir das muss
die neue legislaturperiode machen weil
ich glaube niemand wird sagen dass wir
ohne aufarbeitung hier rauskommen das
heißt sie sagen der nächste bundestag
oder im nächsten bundestag muss ein
untersuchungsausschuss aufklären was in
afghanistan beziehungsweise was an
politik der bundesregierung bezüglich
afghanistan falsch gelaufen ist es gibt
viele möglichkeiten
untersuchungsausschuss ist eine davon ja
poland holz ich möchte noch mal darauf
zu sprechen kommen es kommen unglaublich
wie viele menschen jetzt auch zu uns
nach deutschland
wir haben auch gerade ganz emotionale
bilder gesehen von familien ganz kleine
kinder sind dabei was passiert mit den
menschen wenn sie hier bei uns im land
ankommen
na ja das ist natürlich jetzt erstmal
ein wichtiges thema was momentan so ein
ausreißen stattgefunden hat wenn die
menschen bei uns ankommen die momentan
gerettet worden sind wird wird hier die
sicherheitsüberprüfung gemacht sie
bekommen in dieser erteilt und je
nachdem welche kategorie sind sind sie
zum beispiel ortskräfte haben sie in
unmittelbaren gesetzlichen anspruch aus
unserem aufenthaltsgesetz andere die mit
gekommen sind müssen dann ins
asylverfahren das läuft dann hier in
deutschland jetzt ab und für die zukunft
müssen wir halt sehen dass es wieder in
das ursprüngliche geordnete verfahren
zurückkehrt das heißt eigentlich
visaerteilung und sicherheitsüberprüfung
dann bevor die einreise nach deutschland
erfolgt es gibt warnungen frau lindholz
aber von erhöhter terrorgefahr die durch
die flüchtlinge jetzt aus afghanistan zu
uns kommen auch dann in deutschland
wieder herrschen könnte unter anderem
und ehemaligen bnd chefs sehen sie diese
gefahr auch wie muss man dieser gefahr
begegnet
also wir haben natürlich unsere
sicherheitsbehörden haben immer einen
guten überblick und einblick wer zu uns
ins land kommt und normalerweise macht
man wie gesagt die sicherheitsprüfung
außerhalb des landes das ist auch immer
der zielführenden weg das haben wir
jetzt für einen moment um aufgrund der
sich entwickelnden tage außer kraft
gesetzt das heißt die behörden schauen
jetzt hin und das ist auch das
allerwichtigste wir müssen wissen wer in
unser land kommt und diese kleine lücke
die wir momentan haben dass wir
sozusagen erst hier aktuell die eine
oder andere person prüfen die müssen wir
schnellstmöglich wieder schließen der
innenminister hat in der letzten
ausschusssitzung gesagt für diesen
moment jetzt müssen wir eben den mut zur
lücke haben und ich vertrauen so und
sicherheitsbehörden auch dass sie dann
auch jeder einzelnen identität auch
nachgehen wenn zweifel an der identität
besteht aber wie gesagt wir brauchen für
unser aller sicherheit danach jetzt
wieder den übergang zum gewöhnlichen
verfahren also erst identitäts klärung
dann visum und aus einreise nach
deutschland fragt sich ob man jemals
wieder jemanden nach afghanistan zurück
schicken kann ja mir geht es auch nicht
uns zurückschicken alleine nach
afghanistan also muss es klar sein das
ist jetzt erst einmal ausgesetzt ist und
dass die person jetzt hier eingereist
sind auch erst mal tatsächlich bei uns
sind also wenn da jemand darunter ist
von dem im prinz von dem wir im prinzip
wissen dass er zum beispiel wir uns
schon mal straftaten verübt hat und
wieder eingereist ist haben wir hier
erst mal mit unserer rechtsstaatlichen
mitteln im ganzen zu begegnen die die
abschiebung oder rückführung ist immer
nur ausgesetzt es sollte auch so bleiben
das klingt jetzt natürlich mal wieder
ein bisschen hart aber es ist einfach so
wir dürfen da für die zukunft nicht
ausschließen und für alles weitere was
jetzt kommt wo wir sagen wir wollen
weiterhin menschen helfen zu uns zu
kommen in begründeten fällen da haben
wir die ortskräfte da haben wir
vielleicht auch besonders wenn er atmet
personen die betrifft ist aber hier
nicht so bei allen anderen muss einfach
klar sein dass wir unser bewährtes
verfahren der sicherheitsprüfung vor ein
weise vornehmen anders geht es nicht wir
werden niemals nie die illegale einreise
komplett verhindern können aber auch die
geht's hier an der stelle auch nicht
sondern es geht und die das bewusste
nach deutschland holen von menschen auf
dem luftweg zum beispiel
do
[Musik]